[Musique]
un bon chocolat chaud c'est savourer une
bonne dose de plaisir parce que chocolat
chaud une place importante chine très
importante c'est tellement réconfortant
dans ses restaurants boutiques juliette
propose plusieurs choix du chocolat
chaud leur nom nous rappelle l'histoire
de cette boisson des aztèques en passant
par les médias les européens et les
américains quand on a commencé mon
chocolat chaud les gens disaient mais
c'est parce que la chaussée du pudding
je me suis jamais cessé sa ce que
j'avais l'habitude de consommer quand
j'étais petit avec ma grand mère qui ne
cuisinent et les chats et chevaux un
canton et jouer dehors en hiver
de nos jours toutes bonnes chocolaterie
propose maintenant sa version deluxe de
cet élixir fait à partir de la fève de
cacao
si vous faites une boisson avec du sang
pour sang clause de cacao
ça va être très amer alors naturellement
ici au québec les gens ils ont raison
quand même la dent sucrée on va le dire
comme ça ça veut dire on va on va plutôt
vers un produit qui est un petit peu
plus sucré philippe van 15 il est
directeur de l'académie du chocolat les
enfants qui aiment bien le boire ça
aussi quand c'est déjà un petit peu trop
amer ça devient un petit peu difficile
alors je pense que si c'est une raison
pourquoi des fois on peut avoir
peut-être quelques pourcents plus de
sucre de canne et du sucre
on en trouve souvent beaucoup dans les
préparations de chocolat chaud vendus en
épicerie pour tous les produits à
l'exception
2 le sucre et le premier ingrédient donc
pas de surprise ici encore une fois le
caca houston et grèce est un aliment qui
crèvent la mer donc lyon nos besoins de
sucre filé dans l'univers du bébé
voilà c'est réglé c'est sucré cela dit
la quantité de sucre qui se retrouvent
de l'allant
malgré que ce soit le premier ingrédient
c'est extrêmement variable on peut
passer de 9 g à 1 33 grammes dans une
tasse de chocolat chaud et moins jeunes
vous avez pratiquement cette cuillère à
thé de sucre
c'est énorme
[Musique]
aussi c'est qu'on devra avoir du succès
avec des skieurs pour goûter du chocolat
chaud
[Musique]
vous devant servir beaucoup dans une
cafétéria de centres de ski
marginalement je te dirais même la fin
de semaine passée on ça peut aller un
peu plus logique à 4,5 me bonjour je
voulais soit vers ce qu'est vraiment
avis le goûter
[Musique]
cette grotte polisy mot vivre vraiment
sucrés salés de bouc aux gommes de
cellulose
bonjour fat dipotassique heures
est-ce que tu connais tous les mondes
qu'est-ce que se trouve un quart ben
alors vous allez goûter c'est lui qui
contient dabach du cacao plutôt que du
sucre comme premier ingrédient celui de
votre part choisi le 18 48 aussi un goût
bizarre c'est bizarre quand on est dans
les produits comme celui de sélection on
est à 28 grammes de sucre donc 5
cuillerées et demi de sucre
à jeter
1/4 de tasse de mélange à chocolat chaud
sélection trouve que c'est beaucoup
beaucoup alors ajouté sort avait été
vous toujours en perspective si vous le
faisiez vous même à partir d'une pâte de
cacao cru et vous allez le sucré
allez-vous naturellement lève 5 ou 7
cuillérées à thé de sucre sans doute
jamais et puis qu'est ce que tu en
penses
quand un produit comme celui ci nous
parle de vitamines a b c est de faire
parce que c'est vrai oui c'est
effectivement dans le produit
mais honnêtement je sais même pas
pourquoi nestlé ont voulu aller dans
cette direction là c'est un breuvage
d'occasions c'est un breuvage plaisir
aux propos de nourrir un enfant avec son
puisse se fier sur d'une excuse pour lui
donner ces vitamines et minéraux sans
aucun sens
parmi les produits contenant le moins de
sucre ces chocolats chauds en deux aides
c'est pas juste parce qu'ils ont moins
de sucre mais c'est parce qu'ils sont
notamment et dulko rick donc on la
présence de stévia dans celui du choix
du président acésulfame potassium et
sucralose dans le code de laura secord
donc même si au bois trop de sucre dans
le tableau de valeur nutritive
attendez-vous parce que ce soit pour
sucrer ça va être très sucré signe de
popularité du chocolat chaud certains
fabricants adaptent leurs tablettes de
chocolat bien connu en version à boire
pourquoi choisir les cafés que j'aime
bien ce crime là on tombe dans l'univers
vraiment purement du marketing
jusque là c'est non seulement très sucre
ibis et parmi les produits qui
contiennent le plus d'actifs chimiques
les produits contenant des substances
laitières modifiés sont souvent ceux
avec le plus d'e10 tiff et ça j'avoue
que ça m'a dérangé les chocolats chauds
qui ne contiennent pas d'ingrédient
betty semble être dans l'ensemble
beaucoup plus naturellement la
recomposition d'un produit à l'autre
le mode d'emploi dari certains demandent
d'ajouter de l'eau d'autres du lait
c'est le gros débat lannoy je ne fais
plus avec de l'eau parce que ça va
vraiment plus ressortir du goût du
chocolat que la matière grasse est quand
même un transporteur de goût ça veut
dire sa vaquin rendre un produit plus
onctueux plus goûteux qu'est ce que tu
as choisie est ce que tu connais sans
chef et des shows à la banane ces deux
produits ne sont pas des chocolats
chauds traditionnels populaires en
france
ils contiennent en plus du cacao et du
sucre des céréales
parmi les ingrédients on a des céréales
maltais s'est présenté en europe presque
comme un substitut de reports mais
attention rien qu'un gramme de protéine
partage l'attend donc s'épanouissant
d'où les prix varient beaucoup d'un
produit à l'autre ça va de 3 à 13
dollars l'emballage
mais ce qu'il faut surtout regarder
c'est la quantité de poudre exigés pour
chaque tasse c'est ça qui détermine
vraiment le prix de chaque produit
si je prends ce produit-là de monbalen
qui sont foudroyés partance et 5 en
dessous alors que si je prends un
produit comme celui de starbucks par
exemple son coût de revient partance et
le double alors à tout est relatif si on
a un palmarès à faire pour aider les
consommateurs
ça ressemblerait à quoi si on est prêt à
mettre le prix chocolaterie bombannes à
13 heures entre 6 et 10 dollars mes
préférés sont le camino intensément noir
le 1848 de poulin et dans les marques un
peu plus industrielle en france et
starbucks double chocolat et dans nos
produits les moins chers
mes coups de coeur vont à terra et sont
vraiment pas mettre le prix mais essayer
autre chose que le classique des squeak
carnation simplement chocolat chaud peut
faire un bon travail a beaucoup
[Musique]